je fais pourtant depuis presque un an je
suis à l'école et c'est depuis depuis le
printemps
ils le voient bien sa carrière mathieu
en ligne droite tout tracé idéalement ce
serait partir avec une petite compagnie
régionale
il est instructeur chez cargair à
saint-hubert la plus grande école de
pilotage au canada sur trois campus elle
diplôme environ 200 pilotes par année
avec une flotte de 60 avions
il débute sur ces cessna daniel adams et
directeur de carrière un étudiant qui
est admis chez nous au programme deux
pilotes de ligne peut compter environ 18
mois de formation ce qui inclut six
cents heures de formation théorique
environ un peu plus de 200 heures de
formation en vol entraînement en
simulateur après les cessna on passe au
bimoteur gros avantage pour une école
car guère à une filiale de transport
nolisé max aviation avec une flotte de
huit appareils des beechcraft king
pouvant transporter de cinq à neuf
passagers dans la logique et dans le
cheminement d'un cursus d'un étudiant
qui termine sa formation chez car guerre
devient instructeur pour une partie par
la suite dès que son stage
d'instructeurs si vous voulez terminer
alors
l'étudiant a la possibilité de penser
s'il vous plaît à titre de premier refus
si sur l'un de nos avions de transport
chez max aviation et par la suite
tout est possible c'est cela que vous
faites folle et par les autres pays
oui si on peut dire c'est nos pilotes à
ce niveau là sont très très très en main
l'aviation civile connaît un boom
spectaculaire beau y vient de publier
ses prévisions et elle parle de pénurie
dans les 20 prochaines années le monde
aura besoin de sept cent
quatre-vingt-dix mille nouveaux pilotes
le double des effectifs actuels il y a
effectivement pénurie dans certaines
régions du monde en asie
particulièrement d'ailleurs car guerre
forme des classes entières de jeunes
pilotes pour de grandes compagnies
aériennes chinoises
la moitié de ces diplômés sont étrangers
chinois est aussi français
il y est ici non seulement parce que la
formation est bonne et moins cher mais
aussi pour rester au canada en suit donc
les très grandes compagnies de niveau 1
comme air canada recrute au niveau 2
chez les compagnies régionales
jean laroche dirige le campus de dorval
du cqf à le centre québécois de
formation aéronautique qui forment pour
moitié des pilotes de ligne et à parts
égales des pilotes de brousse et
d'hélicoptères
le cqf a fait partie du cégep de
chicoutimi
il forme annuellement et gratuitement
une quarantaine de pilotes après une
forte sélection un candidat sur huit et
retenir les compagnies se sont
restructurées en termes de formation
interne pour accueillir des candidats
peut-être un peu plus jeunes avec
peut-être un peu moins d'heures de vol
qui avait 20 ou va qu'on avait à 20 ou
25 ans ce sont de très belles heures de
vol aujourd'hui alors que la formation
s'est adaptée ça va très bien qu'on
croit que le potentiel est dans nos
employés en partage
au québec on peut citer le cas de nos
lino par exemple réussi à créer un
environnement de travail fort
sympathique très accueillants très
dynamique cette année
[Musique]
exemple à suivre au canada c'est le
transporteur d'envergure nationale jazz
qui est impliquée dans la formation
collégiale depuis plus d'une décennie
car guerre et max aviation c'est le
niveau 3 le plus affectés qu'ils
demandent aux grands transporteurs ceci
s'est enlevée en mesure de former
suffisamment pile pour combler vos
besoins
mais on veut surtout savoir et avoir un
plan vous en avez besoin de combien et
quand surtout qu'un vous savez lorsque
vous perdez 50% de votre personnel une
fois par année
ça peut être déstabilisant ce
recrutement difficile serait allégé si
les femmes étaient davantage attiré par
le pilotage
cette jeune femme qui aimeraient bien
piloter chez air transat est encore une
exception près on va les faire
maastricht sont restreints pour préparer
quelques uns sont devenus donc pour
voler de nuit c'est pas de vol aux
instruments mais ça peut demander
certains soirs il n'y a pas cette femme
dans notre industrie
je voudrais de même que le recrutement
des femmes dans notre industrie c'est un
échec pilote est encore un métier
d'homme blanc il faut de la diversité et
il faut le dire les grandes compagnies
font maintenant de gros efforts de
recrutement avec moins de 10% fendre
d'un cockpit
oh c'est clair face à nous préoccupe
depuis de longues années les jeunes
filles se présentent pas aux portes des
écoles de pilotage c'est très
préoccupant ça et puis on met beaucoup
d'énergie chaque année pour rejoindre
les jeunes et venez venez à l'école
femmes ou hommes les jeunes canadiens
sont encore un peu réticent à se lancer
dans le pilotage
on se souvient des difficultés encore
récente du secteur aéronautique
ils doivent se lancer c'est le moment on
recommande aux jeunes ne pas écouter
leurs parents c'est surtout les parents
que les et journaux et qui y voient d'un
oeil pessimiste la carrière l'aviation
au canada l'aviation c'est une carrière
exceptionnelle
on a un marché exceptionnel c'est le
moment c'est le teint les planètes sont
alignées
mathieu lui est sûr de son coup d'après
vous c'est un bon moment maintenant pour
devenir pilote de ligne c'est le maire
m'a c'est la réouvrir les gros alliances
et les gros airbus
c'est pour le mode de vie
les conditions sont réunies avec ça